mir ging es vorhin darum dass auch
Ludwig Erhard gesagt hat 50% von
Wirtschaft ist auch eine Frage der
Stimmung absolut der der Philosophie und
in der Tat mache ich mir Sorgen und ich
will das gar nicht sagen dass wir auch
zu einfach alles ist die ampelschuld die
Ampel kann nichts zu den weltweiten
weltweiten Krisen die entstanden sind
die haben sich sogar überlebt also wir
sind mit Corona angefangen dann haben
wir jetzt äh Ukraine daraus
zusammenhängt energiepreiserhöhung aber
ich habe schon das Gefühl dass das viel
geredet wird und dass wir in erster
Linie ein klimaminister haben und keinen
Wirtschaftsminister wenn wir reden
permanent übers Klima so wichtig das ist
ich glaube dass man die Bekämpfung des
Klimawandels kompatibel machen muss mit
wirtschaftlicher Prosperität weil ich
glaube wenn wir den Wohlstand verlieren
dann ist die Bereitschaft Einbußen
hinzunehmen in Bezug auf Klimawandel und
alles was dafür notwendig ist nicht
besonders groß vorhanden und deswegen
kann ich das nur nüchtern feststellen
das ist richtig analysiert worden auch
von großen Instituten die sagen
Deutschland wird nach hinten durch nicht
gereicht wir haben massive Probleme
ich bedauere genau wie Sie Herr Hahne
das insbesondere Familienunternehmen die
ja eigentlich auch persönlich haften die
ja eigentlich auch sozusagen das
wirtschaftliche Gerüst dieses Landes
darstellen und nicht in erster Linie
große Manager von großen
Industrieunternehmen auch da wünsche ich
mir dass wir Industrieland bleiben wir
müssen es schaffen Industrieland zu
bleiben und trotzdem sozusagen den
Klimawandel sinnvoll bekämpfen zu können
aber wenn ich jetzt sehe dass wir
ideologisch geprägt bei einem massiven
Angebot Nachteil was Energie betrifft
nicht bereit sind darüber nachzudenken
z.B Kernkraftwerke länger laufen zu
lassen als jetzt bis April dann habe ich
dafür wenig Verständnis werden
angebotsschock feststellt muss dafür
sorgen dass das Angebot erweitert wird
und da kann ich nicht sagen ich möchte
den Lebensraum von henritin nicht
zerstören deswegen darf dürfen
funktionierende Kernkraftwerke die im
Zweifel auch sicher sind denn
später von den TÜV jeweils überprüft und
dann auch noch bestätigt alles was da am
Anfang erzählt wurde hat sich ja nicht
so als zutreffend erwiesen dann verstehe
ich nicht dass offensichtlich Ideologie
Vorrang hat vor Vernunft und manchmal
denke ich auch sag mal der Ideologe und
der Idiot haben auch denselben Wortstamm
oder ohne dass ich jetzt damit
irgendjemanden beleidigen will oder
irgendjemand persönlich meine das ist es
nicht ich wünsche mir einfach dass wir
auch bereit sind nicht ideologischer
Freihandelsabkommen zu gucken wie lange
haben wir ceta also mit Kanada ein ein
Freihandelsabkommen ein Land das Europa
so ähnlich ist wie kaum ein anderes auch
die gleichen Werte teilt dass man dafür
sieben Jahre braucht bis man so einen
Freihandelsabkommen abschließt ist mir
ein Rätsel weil es unserer Wirtschaft
nutzt und deswegen glaube ich dass wir
da dass die Ampel jetzt endlich auch
gefragt ist sozusagen von dem von dem
Jahr des erwägens und Abwägens endlich
zum Jahres Handeln zu kommen und im
übrigen auch ideologische Scheuklappen
abzulegen und endlich das zu tun was die
eigenen die eigenen Wirtschaftsweisen
und sach zuständigen sagen Frau Grimm
einstimmig mit ihrem gesamten Rat der
die Bundesregierung berät Last Schnitzer
Last ja Frau Schnitzel auch lasst die
Kernenergie ja nicht die Chefin die
sagen es ja alle übereinstimmt lasst die
Kernenergie für eine Zeit lang laufen so
lange wie diese Energiekrise haben
ins Wirtschaftsministerium oder sind sie
auch der Auffassung sie sind fast beim
klimaschutzminister zu Gast sowie das
eben gerade ausgeführt wurde tragen Sie
diese Punkte mit rein teilen Sie die ich
kann da nicht drüber reden
im Beirat besprechen das ist eine andere
Geschichte das ist vertraulich und da
kommen zum Schluss Gutachten Texte raus
und die sind dann veröffentlicht die
kriegen ja
auf die Füße die Energiewende ist muss
auch nachgebessert werden es ist zwar
richtig dass wir weltweit in eine
Energiewende brauchen aber wir können
nicht ohne rateral hier in Europa die
Energiewende machen und der Rest der
Welt hustet uns was durch ist wenn wir
jetzt ist alles wenn wir jetzt die
Brennstoffe für die Autos zum Beispiel
nicht mehr verwenden weil wir unsere
Autos Fehlentscheiden mit Strom fahren
und der Strom wird man wegen aus Kohle
gemacht dann was passiert mit den
Brennstoffen die Brennstoffe
bleiben ja nicht in der Erde sondern die
werden über die Marktprozesse in andere
Länder geliefert die Tanker machen
einfach eine Kurve um Europa und bringen
das nach Asien wir fahren gar nicht erst
hier hin um uns herum nutzen alle gerne
Energieberg sagt gerne Energie
nur die deutschen grünen sagen das geht
doch
glaube ich vergessen wer den
Atomausstieg durchgezogen
aus meiner Nähe nicht aber
Angela Merkel und jetzt ist man ja auch
nicht so weit dass man sagt moment mal
wir bauen neue mein Eier ist sogar ein
bisschen rum mit ach soll das noch
überbringen
ist Geschichte aber wer Gegenwart ist
und das viel schlimmer gemacht
persönlich hat erklärt als
Finanzminister Umweltminister in Bayern
wenn ich sofort die Kernkraftwerke
abgeschaltet werden trete ich zurück ja
lassen sie noch zurückhaltend
wir alle lernen im Laufe der Zeit ja
die richtige Meinung sind
abzuschalten er ist nun das idiotische
spricht sich explizit doch dafür aus dem
Arbeit er ist doch schön man kann man
denn jemanden vorwerfen dass er seine
Meinung aufgrund neuer Informationen
geändert hat
warum Entschuldigung was muss
immer bei seiner nein
nein also das wieder da widerspreche ich
und zwar es ging ja nicht darum um
Wirtschaftlichkeit es ging um Sicherheit
das heißt Herr Söder ist jetzt dafür
dass die von ihm als unsicher
dargestellte Energie jetzt plötzlich
angeschaltet hat vielleicht neue
Informationen dass das mit der
Sicherheit
dazu
gehören das kann es doch geben auch dazu
gelernt
aber nein
also das lasse ich mir jetzt nicht
anhängen wenn nein
Söder damals gesagt hätte wir brauchen
aus
wirtschaftlichen Gründen weil wir
Alternativen haben keine Atomkraftwerke
dann würde ich sagen wunderbar wenn man
die Meinung dann revidiert aber
irgendwie gefährlich aber bei der
Gefährlichkeit muss man auch abwägen und
jetzt wir sind jetzt nicht mehr
gefährlich doch aber wir haben uns mit
anderen Gefahren zu tun mit Putin haben
wir es zu tun und den Gefahren die mit
dem Krieg zu tun haben und so weiter das
heißt also auch man muss diese
verschiedenen neuen Gefahren
ungefährlich oder sind sie nicht ach das
ist keine 01 Geschichte alles im Leben
ist gefährlich wenn die Straße
übertragen
aber ich heiße ja nicht Söder
dazu gelernt ne die CDU ist in der Lage
offensichtlich auf veränderte
Rahmenbedingungen auch eine veränderte
Politik zu machen wenn man wenn man dazu
nicht in der Lage ist kann man in der
Tat zu Hause bleiben
denn wir hatten diese Bedingungen und
das ist ein Krieg in Europa in dem
Ausmaß geben würde war zum Zeitpunkt wo
sich auch Frau Merkel entschieden hatte
damals als Kanzlerin aus der kennen
Energie auszusteigen ob das jetzt
richtig oder falsch war in meiner
Fraktion haben das auch viele anders
gesehen und das mal klar zu sagen aber
ja die sehen das auch heute noch anders
der der fakt ist nur deswegen stört mich
das so ein bisschen wenn man nur
zurückguckt wenn sie nur in den
Rückspiegel gucken fahren
man ist zum Beispiel auch bereit den
Ausbau voranzutreiben so wie Frankreich
das gerade also mein
Fraktionsvorsitzender hat sich da klar
positioniert der eiert auch nicht rum
wie sie es glaube ich vorhin erwähnt
haben aber das hat man glücklicherweise
nicht gehört weil die beiden Herren
sicher gestritten
aktuell ganz klar gesagt versteht nicht
ja er versteht nicht dass man im
Bewusstsein einer massiven Energiekrise
eines angebotsschocks nicht alle alle
Energiequellen nutzt das ist unsere
Auffassung dazu gehört irgendwie nicht
nur Kernkraft sondern auch regenerative
Energien
Kernkraftwerke ablehnen aber braun Kohle
und Kohlekraft im CO2 schädlich ohne
Ende deswegen sind die Grünen aus meiner
Sicht auch in der Hinsicht keine
überzeugende umweltschutzpartei mehr
sondern nur noch eine Anti akw-parteien
ganz klar gesagt wir haben jetzt erstmal
gesagt als cdu/csu und in persona meines
Vorsitzenden dass wir für eine begrenzte
Zeit warum wird wieder begrenzte Zeit ja
recht ich sollte ja jetzt mal schildern
was mein Fraktionsvorsitzender gesagt
hat bitte damit das jetzt keine
fleischverständlich egal ja die habe ich
auch
wenn wir eine neue Generation von von
Kraftwerken habt muss man sich auch
angucken was entsteht dann noch wie
sicher sind die das sind Fragen die muss
man den muss man sich dann auch neu
stellen aber weil nach unserer Position
gefragt wurde die ist eindeutig dass wir
sagen angesichts der derzeitigen
Situation brauchen wir einen längeren
Betrieb der Kernkraftwerke bis 2024
damit wir in der Lage sind die durch den
Ukraine Krieg entstehenden Energie
Probleme zu lösen im Übrigen noch mal
nicht nur keine Energie sondern ein
breites Angebot wir müssen jede Chance
nutzen denn das es gibt viele das gibt
zwei 24 ist einfach nur die mit und dumm
kommen für dumm halte ich das deshalb
nicht
dazu
ist das noch was soll denn das
nächstes Jahr wollen sie sagen jetzt
aber noch ein Jahr sagen ja machen sie
es doch wenn sie mir genau zugehört
haben haben sie vielleicht auch zugehört
oder gehört dass ich gesagt habe solange
wir diese Energiekrise haben und das ist
Teil dieser Geschichte ja warum ja dazu
gehört also mach dir ja oder nein
keine neuen Kernkraftwerke das hat ja
auch übrigens nur Sinn wenn man die
jetzt laufen lässt endlos also
Entschuldigung wenn wir jetzt an diesem
Tisch sind sie haben mir darauf
hingewiesen Herr Söder ist der so
großartig der ist ja jetzt hat sich
bekehrt sozusagen zur Kernenergie das
heißt ja zu deutsch wenn ich jetzt
anschalte gehe ich davon aus riesigen
geht's überall sie Bergwerk Unglücke sie
ist sinnvoll und sie ist sicher und ich
kann das Anschalten und dann frage ich
mich die Begrenzung ist doch absolut
bescheuert wenn ich dieser Meinung bin
sage ich ich lasse die so lange laufen
ja sie ist ja nicht sicher das weiß doch
jeder dass sie nicht sicher ist aber sie
ist auch nicht so unsicher wie die Leute
tun in der Statistiken dazu wo die
meisten Leute sterben relativ zu
erzeugen und Sie werden sich wundern das
ist die Kohle das haben 10000 Leute
jedes Jahr 100.000 davon an Lungenkrebs
20.000 kommen in den Minen um so ist es
und vor allem auch bei der Grünen
Energie haben wir das Problem das ist
auch leider Tote gibt relativ zu dem
bisschen Energie was da erzeugt wird
sind es viele Tote die stehen an der
Spitze der Statistik jeder möge bitte
Google Statista Tote bei der
Energieerzeugung dann sieht dann eine
Tabelle weil die Klempner eben vom Dach
fallen ja das ist ja es ist super
Energie wenn ich das in Relation nehme
dann sind sie wieder an der Spitze und
sie kriegen also aus
ich hoffe er kriegt zwei